bu TT I think we're disappointed we were  hopeful we'd get a better sentence it  didn't work out I can't say that we're  really surprised it's kind of we didn't  think that there was that much had  changed are we disappointed yeah sure  we're disappointed  I don't think realistically listen I'm  not I'm not very realistic I believe as  I think people should understand what I  said in there this is the worst  injustice in the history of American  jurisprudence it's awful okay  and I'm hopeful I'm a believer in our  judicial system and so when you get into  one of these situations we keep we keep  fighting it and we're going to continue  fighting it and I think we're going to  be successful eventually you'd plan on  giving a slightly longer statement  however you couldn't see it because you  were standing behind him but he did  become very emotional and he just  couldn't finish  you